c'est bonjour pierre c'est obligatoire
faut porter un masque en permanence dans
la rue dès que vous sortez dehors il
faut le porter ma chef c'est pour votre
sécurité et celle des autres d'accord
des policiers intransigeant à mandelieu
la napoule le port du masque est
désormais de rigueur dans les zones à
forte concentration
pour la police il est surtout question
d'assurer la sûreté sanitaire de la
population donc les conditions sont
simples les gens qui vont être dans la
rue forcément ils auront à mon avis à
90% le masque et ceux qui ne l'auront
pas les policiers qui vont les contrôles
et leur proposeront un masque et en plus
de 100 leur précisera comment faire pour
récupérer un kit si malheureusement ces
gens n'ont pas eu de deux kits ce qui
fait que c'est une mission qui est
beaucoup plus paternaliste qu'autre
chose on ne pense pas du tout à la
verbalisation
donc comment vous en donner un et on va
prendre vos coordonnées par contre parce
qu'on est obligés quand les distribuer
de prendre les coordonnées pour savoir
si demain on vous l'a déjà donné quoi
deux simples préconisations lors du
premier contrôle
la mairie a assuré la distribution de
250 mille masques aux quelques 23 mille
habitants de la ville vous n'avez pas de
madame oui quand je rentre dans le
magasin ah non non non non content de
rentrer directement que je vois des gens
et c'est pareil dehors madame mais pour
les plus récalcitrants
lamonde pour non respect du port du
masque peut monter jusqu'à 38 euros une
initiative qui divise les riverains avec
tout ce qui se passe je pense que c'est
une très bonne idée que le maire a pris
une très belle initiative pour ça parce
qu'il ya beaucoup de gens que je pense
qu'ils ne respectent pas beaucoup et
voilà moi je pense que c'est très bien
il protège un peu les autres et je me
protège moi même donc oui quelque part
oui je me sens je me sens mieux mais il
doit me donner un masque si je le mets
pas une amende comme je suis pas fou au
point de payer l'amendé je prends le
match je lui m sera content et après
livre à moi de pas le garder tout
simplement
si on veut essayer de sortir de de tout
ça il faudrait mettre tous les moyens de
l'autre côté
je pense que ça serait bien que ça soit
mis au niveau national une mesure
également mises en place dans la ville
de cannes dans les transports en commun
et les lieux très fréquentés
malgré son application le décret reste
sous la menace d'être retoqué